Nintendo is underway near Singapore for
10 missing US Navy sailors their ship
the USS John S McCain collided with a
600 foot oil tanker yesterday the guided
missile destroyers hold was seriously
damaged crew members sleeping quarters
and other areas were flooded five other
sailors were injured President Trump
tweeted last night thoughts and prayers
are with our US Navy sailors aboard the
USS John s McCain the collision near the
Singapore Naval Base is the second
involving a u.s. Navy ship in the last
two months Ben Tracy is in Beijing with
new information Ben good morning
good morning so the warship docked in
Singapore just a few hours ago and
investigators are now trying to figure
out what caused this collision the USS
McCain is a crew of more than 300 and it
was making what they call a routine pork
visit when this happened this video shot
during the search and rescue operation
shows a large hole in the side of the
USS John S McCain it extends below the
waterline which caused parts of the
guided missile destroyer to flood the
collision happened east of Singapore and
the Strait of Malacca one of the busiest
shipping lanes in the world the u.s.
warship collided with a 30,000 ton oil
and chemical tanker more than three
times its size Kevin Eyre is a retired
Navy captain yes these chips have radars
they have other sophisticated systems
which they can use to identify ships
around them but beyond a certain point
you have dozens of ships within perhaps
a five square mile box all milling about
the search and rescue operation involves
ships and aircraft from the US Malaysia
in Singapore at least four sailors were
evacuated by helicopter to a nearby
hospital they are expected to survive
this is the second collision involving a
u.s. Navy ship in the Pacific in just
the past two months seven sailors died
in June when the USS Fitzgerald in a
container ship hit each other off the
coast of Japan the captain of the
Fitzgerald was relieved of his command
and several other sailors are being
punished for poor seaman ship the crews
the officers the commanding officer are
all extremely well trained this is the
cost
of having one of the world's most
complex navies operating at sea 24/7
around the world the USS McCain is named
after Senator John McCain's father and
grandfather they were both Admirals in
the Navy and Senator McCain did tweet
about this he said that he is keeping
the sailors on the ship in his prayers
and that he appreciates the work of the
search and rescue crews he'll Ben Tracy
and Beijing thanks